so URL URL yes thank you is Leroy
backwards my dad's name really yes
you're all with calling the diversity
room I've been off and on down here for
18 years and I'm 30 was a temporary
young age 14 years old 14 grownup I was
um I was actually a foster child
um starting at the chills my mother was
a drug addict she used to be down here
she um I'm not reading she was a really
bad drug addict she tried to kill me
five times as a kid I was the only
dark-skinned one and I guess I reminded
her of my dad and so she just wasn't
having it and she gave me to my dad at
eight years old that's well I was taking
into the foster system and because my
dad you know there's if there was
anything in the world I could take back
I do over I would be quiet when the
teacher told me to be quiet
cuz that I wouldn't be down here I went
to school one day in a Leena's drug got
into an argument and I was like you mean
what six six fifty five six great and um
the girl was talking back and I was
talking you shut up stupid you shut up
stupid it teachers like right you guys
be quiet you know you got a green card
yellow card ready card to go take home
to your behinds and teachers send me
outside cuz I thought to go shut up your
stupid head and uh
she gave me a red card sent me outside
of the classroom and then they sent me
home my dad came home and said oh you
got a red car because you don't know how
to be quiet right and he snatched
extension cord from the back of the TV
and just start wailing on me and uh I
got bruises I had bruises here this one
here took a long time to heal up that's
why I got the tattoo eater because um it
was a big bruise here
for their central core yeah from the
extension cord and um I went to school
next thing with this big bomber jacket
on it was like a hundred degrees and the
teachers like take the jacket off you
know it's hot I'm like no it's not I'm
calling them sweating bullets
so I pass out and I go to the nurse's
station because I passed out and they
take the jacket off and we've seen all
the bruises on me and from there a bunch
of white people can't rushing in and
police and it's okay you're wrong with
us now and and from there I was on
it was on I was on my own so I always
figured from that room my parents I'm
grown so that's my first foster home
before I went to my dad I was already
sexually active because the fact that my
uncle raped me at eight years old
so um it was like no thing for me to
have sex with the foster dad things like
that what they wanted me to do
it was the Easter Sunday and I'm my
auntie I just got done doing my hair
like little ponytails and things like
that and I was going up the stairs and I
could see my uncle watching me because
in watching me so as I'm going into the
apartment I stopped to the kitchen give
me something to drink for us and I grab
my bread bucket and I go into the room
as I'm trying to reach to put the bread
bucket up on me counter he grabs me like
I have no chichi so he's just like
grabbing rub and all of a sudden the
door closes in he just climbs on top of
me he's like this is that just just
relax just relax I said well let's see
once we'd come downstairs we've got to
go good those Easter eggs we got to find
Easter eggs he said I got a used to egg
for you just stay right here I'll give
you all of them just stay right here and
it happened and it's just the sharpest
pain ever like it [ __ ] it will say
hurt me so bad I couldn't even scream
I can't even scream and we'll finish
like mine she was still sitting on
stairs so I'm gonna cigarette like
nothing ever happened like like you're
not asking where your niece was nothing
and I remember I couldn't walk nothing I
can uh it tore it tore me literally yeah
you know it's uh but you know and I
still see that sick [ __ ] to this day
yeah he comes down he's a drug addict
yeah he just says little smart [ __ ] like
I got a head of doubts for you I go
no smart [ __ ] but out yeah from 12 years
older I was I was having sex and well I
ran away and I went to this guiding st.
Lewis and he lived in MacArthur Park and
I started this one start of it and now I
want to figure on Imperial that's why I
took my first hit crack cocaine mmm
I was prostituting me I had a pimp and
he gave me ten rocks and he was like
just bringing back $50 I'm like okay so
I get in a car with a chick I do that I
got the $50 I don't want these drugs on
because I know they're illegal
yeah like 14 min 13 14 so I see this
crackhead on my hey you want this she's
like what all of this I'm like yeah just
take you just take it I got the money
she's like you don't want one I'm like
no I'm good I'm straight so you've gotta
come here so he just smokes on with me
I'm like alright fine we go right on the
Figueroa Imperial and I hit that pipe in
my ears started ringing and my throat
went numb and I went running oh yeah
that was the I was the first I used to
walk around the little flowers in my
hair like I didn't know nothing about
smoke break I just thought it was cool
he got me this high that I want to feel
an unfeeling and a spooky feeling but
you know a note for Lynette it was fine
with me I didn't have to worry about
nothing I was worried about was that
frog nail stuck in my throat
oh yeah regular and um like I was
getting high oh they every day I still
get high all day probably tell but it's
to the point to where I feel that first
hit when I wake up and after that I'm
just smoking just a smoke down Stephen
you're correct you're not 14 14 hmm yep
yeah I remember my mom's to have us look
in the couch for little white things
spare change yeah so did you go to high
school um often on I did like foster
care like off and on I was really young
in continuation of schools but um I did
all of my schooling in juvenile hall and
I just really learned how to read a
temperature thermometer in prison and
that's you learn that in kindergarten so
yeah out here is very real I've been
raped over 12 times yeah so now like
there's one friend of mine he has like
he owns a self-defense class in Little
Tokyo mall so I go up there he shows me
a few things
the main thing is just to kick a man in
the nuts get it over with
I'm gonna net but I'm yeah it's it's
rough I'm here I have no enemies out
here I've been down here 18 years no
enemies I've been in three fights
it's it's the lifestyle that I never
wanted to live and I never thought I
would live like this but and my cousin
just got an offense doing 20 years and
I'm happy because I'm not the only
person down here anymore you know he was
the first person I found out that my
uncle raped me so it's like I'm not
alone anymore and I've seen him
yesterday and it just it made me so
happy because I'm not alone down here
anymore he does not have a face doing 20
years for our London and big robbery the
president I'm me yes I did well I did
four years for a position yeah yeah
Ellis Gary jail I can deal with prison
and not so not so good for me and you
know it's better than jail but I
couldn't do it again I was too scary
yeah so what do you do come on II know
my prostitute yes the prostitute I sell
conversation I said yeah so uh yeah
pretty much
and it's really hard out here for me you
know like I didn't get SSI I don't get
er I don't get food stamps I do nothing
all my money comes from hustling that's
what I learned that's what I do
you did have dreams as a young girl of
some other life dude Lena basketball
player like I always wanted to be a
basketball player I played basketball I
just
[ __ ] I thought it would be something
more like my sister my brother they have
my brother works for a dance studio Las
Vegas like he used to work for Michael
Jackson one at the I think it's the more
MGM or right one of them unless the
storage for the cannery
cannery Hotel my mom she's been 17 years
clean now yeah we did recovery together
for a little bit we weren't careful
together for a little bit
um she's 17 years clean now she still
hasn't apologized for trying to kill me
as a kid like now she's like still kind
of not sure on with it like if me my
sister get an argument she liked me on
my sister side that sort of saying you
know that's [ __ ] up I said well if I
killed myself to mute so better she was
like huh you never know yeah um I got
four kids I have five one is deceased
he died at three years old I have four
kids two boys two girls I would have 11
all together three set the twins and I
for my deceased but it's about four hmm
where do the kids um they're all with
their fathers ones was my mother my own
don't ever just like me and so my mother
she looks just like me it's scary
because they treat her the way they
treated me when I was young then I have
Courtney that's my ride or die baby
she's uh she's probably down here right
now her dad but um she's uh that's my
little gangster baby she just like me
yes
you know she's inventing something she
didn't see if he men get the head blown
off even people seeing people get killed
she's five years old
she's holed five she won't seen a man
get his head blown off her through your
love being down here I mean I'm not
proud of that
that was her dad's fault Mel's not my
fault then I have a three-year-old his
name is Cornelius and he's adopted out
the Union rescue mission I was clean for
a year 15 days and they [ __ ] around
gave me a dirty drug test I don't know
why and he came and got my son then I
have my youngest which is keen and he's
probably at work what is that right now
- yeah and then there's no baby in here
I'm just fat yeah you look very healthy
in Greenford thank you crack for someone
yeah they said a lot of people say that
not believe that it's not like they're
the same it's not you do it's how you do
it they're like what are you doing
smoking pork chops and suckier brillo
and chicken grease I can for real
I just maintain myself I keep up I eat I
sleep that's the main key eat sleep I
mean I'm not um I'm at ease with myself
I mean you know I'm using on that easel
myself I have no worries no issues my
family knows what I do they know what
I'm going through I mean it's not like I
can't go home I choose to be down here I
just don't want memories to go flowing
back in my head in my last show because
that is an issue yeah
my god I poked someone like three nights
ago cuz he called himself plot I'm
crawling into my tent I don't know who
it was but I've hoped him I think it hit
him here
I didn't that's why I keep a lock of my
chin now sleep with my chat locked from
inside Bobby who's got on him there is
no know why he happened to be around
that night and the guy just crawled into
my tent and am i a couple of my
homegirls a guy I crawled into their
generate them recently so I I mean I got
quick hands so I pulled his baby out and
stuck him right through the heart okay
thank you so much for sharing your story
thank you